en el corazón de un valle verde se ubica
la ciudad de mora en el extremo norte de
camerún aquí se goza de una aparente
tranquilidad en una región que lleva 10
años azotada por los ataques de la secta
boko haram
en el corazón de la ciudad este centro
se ha convertido en un símbolo de
esperanza la de un eventual retorno a la
paz el centro acoge a las familias de
los ex combatientes de boko haram ya hay
más de mil 600 residentes ex
combatientes yihadistas que se
entregaron con sus esposas e hijos no
sólo el camerunés es también hay
nigerianos que en su día se alistaron en
la secta voluntariamente o por la fuerza
estos ex militantes islamistas prefieren
mantenerse alejados de nuestras cámaras
los que están dispuestos a dar
testimonio lo hacen anónimamente como
éste exija dista de 27 años que pasó
ocho años en el grupo terrorista antes
de desertar hace unas semanas dice que
aprovechó la ausencia del líder
histórico de la secta abubakar shekau
quien murió hace varios meses pudo
escapar de sí a escondidas hace dos días
y dos noches en el monte bajo la lluvia
para llegar primero a la casa de mis
padres y luego llegué aquí personalmente
me uní a boko haram por voluntad propia
pero tras la muerte de fecao el grupo
dejó de ser tan eficaz y unido e incluso
antes de su muerte ya había
enfrentamientos entre el leal
decidí irme cuando el nuevo líder albarn
aui ordenó matar a mis tres amigos
estaba muy enfadado aquí estamos bien en
comparación con cuando estábamos en el
monte porque aquí tenemos comida agua y
un techo para dormir gratis el centro
que sólo alberga a 154 combatientes
cuando se inauguró en 2018 ahora alberga
10 veces más personas están protegidos
las 24 horas del día por fuerzas de
seguridad en el patio el director de
este centro de reinserción vigilar día a
día estos cientos de ex combatientes su
misión es de radicalizar los
para animar a estos ex milicianos a
abandonar las filas de boko haram el
gobierno camerunés les prometió una
amnistía total incluso para los autores
de crímenes violentos es parte de una
iniciativa para que vuelvan a integrarse
a la sociedad
el objetivo de la rehabilitación en los
centros de the air es ofrecer a estos ex
combatientes una formación adecuada una
formación de su elección
pequeños trabajos que realizarán
posteriormente en la comunidad durante
la reintegración y orden
con tu sala
pero todo esto va a precedido la
atención psicológica en charlas
educativas
y de educación cívica
el número de combatientes que hay son
hormigas que el grupo está debilitado
un grupo terrorista desgarrado por una
guerra interna entre facciones lo cual
aceleró la huida de estos ex
combatientes que ahora buscan un futuro
profesional
a pocos kilómetros de la sede principal
el centro inició un programa de
formación a este ex teniente del grupo
ahora le apasiona la mecánica no tenía
educación alguna cuando se unió a boko
haram a sus escasos 16 años una presa
fácil para el grupo islamista que
recluta principalmente a jóvenes sin
estudios y sin empleo al principio me
uní al grupo yihadista por amigos que ya
estaban ahí venían cada vez a darme 50
mil francos doscientos cincuenta mil
francos prometiéndome que ganaría mucho
más si me unía a ellos me sedujo la idea
pero estando allá me di cuenta de que
mataban y robaban a la gente de los
pueblos para quedarse con sus
propiedades me obligaban a matar a gente
inocente o de lo contrario me matarían a
mí desde que llegué al centro cada vez
que pienso en toda la sangre que derrame
me arrepiento mucho no sabía lo que
estaba haciendo
solo quiero cambiar de vida tener un
trabajo y encontrar familia en este
centro para excombatientes hay unas 550
mujeres esta mujer es secuestrada en
2016 tiene ahora 33 años fue reclutada y
casada a la fuerza con uno de los
milicianos del grupo pudo escapar de su
casa con sus dos hijos nacidos de esta
unión no deseada fue víctima de varios
delitos sexuales nos llevaron a la
fuerza mi hermana y amigos allá éramos
sus esclavas sexuales y no se nos
permitía salir y al menor error nos
mataron a varias mujeres que habían
decidido no respetar sus consignas de
las áreas el que era mi marido me violó
varias veces era un infierno
para los residentes más antiguos el
centro puso en marcha una nueva fase de
reinserción que consiste en que vuelvan
a ser parte de la comunidad algunos de
ellos pueden realizar actividades fuera
del campamento pero deben volver por la
noche en el mercado de mura no hay nada
que indique que este hombre era un
combatiente yihadista hasta hace unos
meses
empecé este trabajo con pocos medios y
recibí la ayuda del centro y de algunos
colegas comerciantes de aquí estoy muy
agradecido con la gente porque desde que
vengo a este mercado nadie me ha juzgado
a pesar de que conocen mi pasado
al igual que los habitantes de la región
los comerciantes del mercado quieren
tener en la redención de estos exija
vistas
desde que está aquí nunca ha hecho nada
malo es tranquilo no tiene tiempo para
salir siempre se queda aquí vienen las 7
de la mañana y se va a las 5 30 de la
tarde
en la frontera entre camerún y nigeria
al tiempo que se multiplican las
deserciones la intensidad de los ataques
también ha aumentado esto es una señal
de la extrema radicalización de los
combatientes que han permanecido fieles
a boko haram
situación que sigue incrementando el
trágico balance de esta insurgencia que
ya ha causado la muerte de al menos
siete mil civiles en camerún casi
350.000 en el lado nigeriano y ha
llevado al exilio a tres millones de
civiles en la cuenca del lago chad
durante los últimos diez años